[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two
lifelong friends talk about life for a
long time
i'm link and i'm right this week at the
round table of dim lighting we're
catching up
with each other and with you we're
talking about our
trips back home to north kakalaki the
first time
that we have been back to the homeland
oh man since pre-kovic
i visited my family
uh over the course of three weeks
three weeks is a long time to be
anywhere that's not where you normally
are
no offense to my family i might offend
them later when i talk about things
you may have already but based on that
whether it's i mean if you have the
luxury of going on a vacation for
three weeks or what i do which i don't
call a vacation
i call it a liaise with family to
reconnect
it's just not you shouldn't go anywhere
longer than two weeks
and two weeks might be pressing yourself
that's why i went for two weeks
unless you're like unless you're some
like
like gap year backpacker person
i've thought about being that and then
you can just who
who who knows no home can i just do a
gap year now
how would that impact you it'd be so
lonely
rhett's on a gap year i think we have to
call it a sabbatical at this point oh
yeah yeah
when he reaches a certain you because we
have we have tenure
you can take a sabbatical and then not
have to worry about
whether you can come back or not do we
have tenure are you i think so i do
do you think that you would i mean like
let's just say for a second
if sabbatical was on the table and it
wouldn't disrupt things
are you telling me that you couldn't do
a sabbatical for more than three weeks
are you saying a sabbatical is different
um first of all is this i've only heard
the word sabbatical
in a in reference to a preacher who like
our professors do it too but pr who who
preaches every sunday at a church and
you know
it's like where's where's pastor jerry
where is well i think the root he's on
sabbatical i think the root of
s which is code for sabbath we're
covering up something
is that it he's having trouble right
yeah yeah pastor jerry had an affair
with the secretary
but uh sabbath is rest right
so it's like is that sabbath so and they
were like we can't say
sabbathical that sounds like an idiot so
sabbatical let's take the h out
i don't know i'm not an entomologist
which i think is someone who studies
insects can you i don't know what the
word is for someone who studies words
uh what is it somebody studies words a
linguist
well i know when he studies languages
the origin of words
a word wordologist i know hold on
jenna's gonna look at it i hate doing
this because i don't know if you're
aware of this but there are people
listening
yeah they're just listening to two old
friends and what is it and there's
two lifelong friends there are so many
of them we should have said two old
friends there's so many of them
listening
that some of them and you know what in
our what is it
they're etymologists entomology no
entomologist insects there's an n
no that's they know it etymology they
knew that
before jenna had to tell us and
somebody's mispronouncing it
it's not end there's no n in it yeah
because that's the one with the insects
oh so the difference between studying
words and insects is the letter n the
letter n
really as an insect everything that we
talk about there's always someone
listening who thinks they know more
yeah that's why i say so many different
things
to make other people feel smart
i want to make oh is that you've been
your motive for all these years i want
to make as many people feel smart as
possible so i touch on a lot of things
but
by asserting your knowledge you're
giving people opportunity to feel
smarter than you
uh in a wide variety i'm a content
individual at this point in my life i'm
not trying to prove anything anymore
um um so i took a two-week sabbatical to
north carolina
i had not seen my family since
thanksgiving to 2019
and i'm gonna i'm gonna i i think
from the little that i've kind of heard
and looking at your visage
i think you've had you had a pretty
pretty
pretty fun trip on a scale of one to ten
uh zero being torture
and a 10 being um like
ecstatic i i was going to say
okay but i don't want to do that to you
in this trip
i don't want to i don't want to put that
on you well it wasn't that kind of trip
jesse wasn't even with you i know that
so
10 being like you you're ecstatic
like the happiest you've ever been i it
was a i mean
it could have been a seven or an eight i
i had some really good times
i'm i'm still processing my trip if i if
you pressed me to give a number right
now
are you what's your number link thanks
for asking
i mean i'd probably say a four i mean
that wasn't too bad
but it could be worse it's nobody's
fault it was
it was the nature of what i was rearing
into
and and some of the stuff i had to
navigate back home
so i want to take this
episode and i just want you to go for it
i want you to give me that
seven or eight experience and then
that's what my mom says when she like
goes to a restaurant and gets french
fries as a side
i'm going for it i'm going for it i want
you to go for it
and then next week i'm going to go for
it in a different way which might
it might have some heavier aspects to
the conversation okay well i feel like
that would be good
i'm going to see how heavy i can get no
my mind mine was just
i've got some good i've got some good
stories some things that happened
um i don't know what it i don't i i've
you know i've kept
the full update at bay yeah yeah i mean
we only had
really one point of textual contact over
the course of my three week
trip and it was an update that you were
you're still alive because you were
texting but apparently
the house that you were staying in at
one point almost caught on fire
possibly that's the only tidbit of
information
that i i that i really would go as far
as to say
it caught on fire so there was a fire
that i will talk about and you weren't
there for july 4th either
no and it wasn't my fault well i'll be
the judge of that
um yeah so that's a tease
there's some other stuff that happened
uh
but you know what i want to do as your
friendly
neighborhood content creator and
concerned citizen
i'm going to dip my toes back in these
waters just real quick
and talk about the vaccine again i'm
gonna be that guy
okay yeah people are still talking about
that vaccine
you know i got it i got it a second time
me too the second one
and i was like well i'm good to go isn't
everybody good to go
and i remember when you talked about it
on this show
and um you know there was a lot of info
and i just kind of zoned out bro because
i'm not going to give it
my decision and i just i you know and i
feel like
either people are gonna people people
wanna listen to stuff they agree with
man
and they don't wanna listen to stuff
that they're not gonna agree with so who
is your audience
for for this little dip in the toe here
as we've already established the only
reason i'm talking about this is to make
other people feel intelligent
okay uh no you're gonna make people who
are fully vaccinated
feeling tough no no so again i don't
know who the audience is
who cares to listen i i'm kind of of a
mind right now that
um if you have decided to not get the
vaccine by this point
there's probably not a whole lot that's
going to cause you to get the vaccine
so i get but but i get so i guess i'm
talking to those people who are still
holdouts and kind of still feel like
there is
there's a crack in the door that i can
kind of stick my foot in right now
um or maybe
a listener knows someone and they can
put their foot in their crack
right in the crack which is not where
the vaccine goes
unless you request it um they'll put the
whole syringe right up your ass
[Laughter]
so and then you squeeze you squeeze
yourself yourself administer and then it
it
it it's no touch it's like it shrinks
this ridge no touch
that vaccine i think you're supposed to
put it in all the way and then
rotate it for a count of five
or is that your swab for the test okay
i'm i think everybody at this point is
beyond the whole
uh hurt immunity thing that's
that's not gonna happen so i'm literally
just beyond the whole that is what they
say when you're putting
i'm just i am only appealing to your own
personal
protection like i tried to do the thing
last time which is like this is we're
all in this together
this is about the population yeah i mean
we're obviously that's not going to
happen there's going to still be a
significant number of people who aren't
vaccinated
and this thing's going to be around for
a pretty good while and it's become it's
going to become endemic and
et cetera et cetera but
the delta variant and now i'm scared
again they're giving it to me with that
delta v
the delta variant has changed the game
and i just want to talk a little bit
about that just very briefly
now uh delta variant significantly more
contagious
than the alpha variant uh now
there's a lot of people and the numbers
are going up very very quickly
the numbers are going up very very
quickly in the states where
most the highest numbers of unvaccinated
people
are and also the people who are going to
the hospital
and experiencing severe illness from
this
are by and large unvaccinated people
again there was some talk back in the
early days of the vaccine
some vaccine conspiracy theorists were
like you know what actually this vaccine
is going to make people more susceptible
to the virus and we're going to see all
these side effects
etc etc those things not surprisingly
have proven to not be true
the safety profile of the vaccine is
what was indicated in the trials
meaning that there is low risk of side
effects and long-term complications
not saying they don't exist but it's
still a very low risk
and also it isn't making people more
susceptible to infection
or more susceptible to severe illness
it's doing exactly the opposite which is
what vaccines are designated to do so
but here's the thing i feel like most
people who haven't gotten it at this
point
chances are that you are in an
environment in a community in a family
uh there's a setting that you're in
where there's a lot of pressure against
getting the vaccine at this point right
here in los angeles
super left-wing situation of course
there's a lot of pressure to get
the vaccine i acknowledge that but
there's a lot of pressure in a lot of
pockets in the in the united states
to to to mock people who get the vaccine
to say i'm not gonna i'm not a guinea
pig don't be a guinea pig and so it's an
accent
you well i'm just saying a lot of it is
in the south and i'm from the south so
i'm just i'm gonna
i'm gonna use that accent now don't
bring guinea pigs into this
um guinea pigs are not native to uh
the south though so my plea at this
point
is is that again the science is pretty
clear
i'm not sure that that is going to make
a difference at this point because
people will believe that
where i'm getting my information from is
not a trustworthy source and that i'm
being lied to et cetera et cetera
so but i'm just appealing to that person
out there
who is like well i actually don't really
know what i think about this
but i'm kind of scared of this delta
variant because one of the things that's
happening is younger people are getting
infected more readily that's who's in
the hospital right now is a lot of
younger people
and the issue we said this before but
i'll just state it again
the issue is not the mortality of covid
that is an issue for people who are
older and who are in high-risk groups
but the issue is long-term complications
long covet and long-term complications
from this virus we're seeing
all kinds of things every day that
passes we get more and more evidence
that the long-term complications
associated with even a mild case of
covid
are this is not a pretty picture
we're seeing the brain fog and we're
seeing people's senses being
uh mess with we're seeing erectile
dysfunction
that'll scare some people there's just
all kinds of things that happen
with unknown novel viruses like this and
that's where the real risk is right now
the real risk is not with the vaccine
on any significant statistical level the
real risk is with
these long-term complications that are
happening to people who are healthy
young vibrant people who exercise have
good diets
the virus don't care so
here's what i'm asking i'm just saying
consider this if you're in a community
where there's a lot of pressure to not
get the vaccine
just get it and don't tell anybody don't
tell anybody don't tell your parents
don't tell your kids don't tell your
spouse
don't tell your preacher just
get the vaccine don't tell your doctor
hold on wait because this is my thing
i if you you got to these nebulous
reasons and like
foggy fears associated with the vaccine
but then it's like why not ask your
doctor
like ask ask the doctor that you trust
that if you were dying
if if you had some conditions i think
i'm dying
i'm going to the emergency room and then
the doctor comes up and says well this
is what you need to do
and you know then you're going to start
searching stuff on the internet and
and and just talking to friends who
are really passionate about certain
things and then you're going to say you
know what
i'm not i'm not going to trust you doc
it's like to talk to your
trusted doctor and take your doctor's
advice and they will almost assuredly
tell you to get the vaccine and they're
not part of a giant conspiracy they're
just
doctors why would you why would you
trust
this a doctor who you barely know
because they're a doctor with your
very life yet not go to them
to to confirm or redirect
your anti-vaccine stance
but it just i don't want you to be one
of these people
that's literally this is what we're
seeing now you got people
in the hospital and the moment before
they get put on a ventilator
or they get intubated they're
asking for the vaccine god please give
me the vax
too late it doesn't work at that point
and listen i'm
serious it's stop fighting the the
culture wars don't tell any don't try to
convince your people do it secretly
do it secretly okay if you if you can't
convince your community and your family
to to think about this uh correctly just
go get it yourself don't tell anybody
don't even tell yourself
just get the vaccine you'll be fine just
you know what you could ask the
the nurse administering the vaccine that
you're that you've
you're meeting with in secret you say
you know what just put it
well we we already have we've already
explored option number one
which is up the rectum that's actually
not our advice
but you could say hey why don't you just
put it put the put the
syringe needle up on the ground and i'm
just going to fall into it
and then it'll be a secret but if
somebody finds out if i'm pressed i'll
be like
i didn't get the vaccine i actually
might have stepped on a nail it was a
no it was an accident i fell into the
vaccine
i fell on it yeah yeah it was definitely
not my i was not willing to
whoop but i am now vaccinated yeah i
fell twice two weeks apart
yeah or is it three weeks i can't
remember i've been enjoying the
vaccination
so long okay got that out of your system
uh and there are people who if you're if
you're skipping this is the point where
you can stop skipping
this is it we're not talking about the
vaccine anymore
unless you get secretly let's take a
second uh to talk about something else
you should get and that is
uh you should get some stuff from the
mythical store mythical.com
we were so fun to buy stuff rip your
boys
and uh we don't we don't sell a vaccine
we've looked into it
um but there are legal implications i i
feel like our content
vaccinates you against
suckier content like that's a haughty
thing to say is it not well
you mean the stuff that we sell at
mythical i'm just hanging in jail you
said content
content i think giving i think buying
stuff at mythical.com vaccinates you
against less cool
things that you can put on your body
clothing
lip balms yeah stuff like that
lotion we got lotion hair product
but we also have something called the
last chance section because we are
constantly releasing new things
and they're all limited runs for the
most part and so
what we do is we give you a chance a
last chance we put it in a section on
the store it's like this is the stuff
that when it's gone it's gone
so you won't miss it if you don't want
to so go to the last chance section of
the mythical store and uh
rep your boys mythical.com okay man
so i experienced what i might call
a tourism
commercial for the state of north
carolina because what is the one thing
that we used to say growing up in north
carolina when people ask us about north
carolina
it's got it's got the mountains and it's
got the beach and it's got the piedmont
i remember at bowie's creek elementary
school the posters that were up
everywhere were not motivational in
nature
they were tourism in nature
they would they would have a picture of
a a scenic part of north carolina and
then it would just say in bold letters
at the bottom
north carolina it's like why i we really
walked the halls of it was like a
a a tourism bureau yeah and so we really
had this appreciation of how much
our home state had to offer well here's
the thing sandy beaches and
and lighthouses and blue ridge parkways
i feel like we have been we were spoiled
we grew up in north carolina and now we
live in california
so from a landscape standpoint options i
never understood
you know there are people who are living
in states that don't have the beach
or the mountains a lot of states don't
have either of those things
and we were just like of course we've
got both of course we're
within two hours driving distance of
both if you live in
the raleigh area you know what i'm
saying like it's a wonderful place by
the way
that place is growing the fastest
growing place in the
nation i think or like one of the top
places right now
is the triangle area and like i haven't
been there in 18 months and just a
couple of
streets that i went on a couple of
routes like going from my
brother and sister-in-law's house to my
brother's house
unrecognizable because there's just so
many communities going on oh my gosh
it's
crazy it just cleared everything out i
mean and
you you go south like you go uh apex
fuquay
down into lillington to bowie's creek
like where i'm like
visiting my kin folk all of the fields
are are now cul-de-sac cookie-cutter
communities
not farming far we're not farming crops
anymore we're farming people
and what are they gonna eat i don't know
how they're building stuff when you
can't get
with the supply chain don't get me
started on the supply chain
yeah i mean the freaking pop houses
popping up everywhere
where are these people coming from well
you know apple's coming in
amazon amazon's coming in amazon came in
it's growing like crazy i mean
i drove through the neighborhood and
it's like
it's an older neighborhood but when we
moved in the trees were short
now the trees are tall and it looks like
some trees
it's meant to be they grow i was blown
away by all these houses they're
building
uh so it's off-putting really i
like experience i experienced the
mountains the piedmont
and the coast over a period of two weeks
and really i experienced the mountains
in the beach i just drove through the
piedmont
i i i spent one night
maybe two nights in fuquay but then it
was the beach i mean it was the
mountains and the beach
and uh boy you know i was like
i took this place for granted but this
is a nice i mean of course i've got both
of those things
too here now nobody lives at the
mountains or the beach
so well there's quite a population there
but you mean people that i
though you're relating my family i mean
you went all the way home i didn't see
anybody
i know no so your approach actually
jesse came up with the idea
to take and again uh yes jesse
and locke it was just me and shepard
the story on that essentially is that
they all went back
before like two weeks before for some
other events
locke's had a lot of stuff going on this
summer getting ready for college
job etc so lock and jesse ended up
staying at home
just me and shepard went but it was
jesse's idea
that we'd do something with the
mclaughlin clan
in uh the mountains of north carolina
which interestingly
you know a few years ago we took the
mclaughlin clan to
scotland to find out they were irish
uh but we uh and to break your mom's
ankle and break my mind
and interestingly and technically we're
scotch irish so a little bit of both
but you know the scot the scotch irish
people
migrated to america and largely settled
in the appalachian mountains and so a
lot of the things that you see
because we were near grandfather
mountain which we'll talk about that in
a second banner elk
grandfather mountain area a lot of the
things you see out there
are sort of scottish or irish themed
a lot of scottish themed stuff including
the the highland games like the north
carolina's version of the highland games
is right there on grandfather mountain
every single year and it was there while
we were there and we didn't realize it
we
actually the day we got there was the
last day of it and we didn't realize it
until the next day so we
missed it uh but it was interesting so
you basically decided to
like plan a vacation and then your your
family was going to drive
you flew into rdu right you didn't fly
to rdu and satan if you quit for a
couple nights then we
then we drove and then all the
mclaughlins you guys went to the
mountain
you've never done that before it's not
like you were carrying on something
nobody
you know we've got an idea we've learned
especially
if you can get everybody together in one
place like getting everybody away from
their homes and getting into this like
this nice log cabin up in the mountains
like the on basically on grandfather
mountain
it it really looking out your entire
vacation right because it it changed
from just being i'm going to visit with
you
and where are we going to eat now yeah
right yeah and so we made plans for an
activation together
plans for an activity every single day
and then reservations at a restaurant at
night and you just were like this is
what we're going to do
we went and everybody's of of health to
be able to do that
yeah well mom and dad tends to to be
like
i just want to watch y'all have fun
together sure
and so because we did she was able to
make that drive well yeah
yeah she can take the she could take the
drive but she didn't white water raft
we went white water raft what we went uh
all the kids went
ziplining while my brother and my dad
and i played golf in the
in the mountains which was great uh
we went on the alpine roller coaster so
there's this thing
that comes down the mountain you know
those like european style roller
coasters where you're just
in a car unlike us by yourself or
some sort of half-past it's based on
those that aren't safe that you can like
do in europe like back in the old days
there was one in slovakia but it's not
on a track and it's not attached to
anything and you have a pull break
that's the old-school one yeah i've seen
those on instagram the new ones
this new one is like two years old it is
fully on a track it's obviously very
safe but you
you control it and you have a handbrake
and you go down
you get like three rides um shout out to
the the staff at this place they were a
bunch of mythical beasts there
what place you can't shout out i think
it's called alpine
you know it's it's in banner elk it's
the out just alpine roller coaster
so that's called something like that and
uh
we went uh what else did we do
we went uh how long of a ride was that
like is it like a water slide length or
was it like you get
so long that you would get bored was it
scenic was it fast
i think it takes probably two minutes to
come down it which is
i mean that's pretty i mean that's like
a regular roller coaster length
and then you could just go you just buy
three rides if you want and you just
stay on the cart and go right back up
well the rise of the resistance
at disneyland is like a 20-minute ride
oh well this is not disneyland
this is the alpine roller coaster i mean
i'm so jealous i'm just trying to
you know i also paid like i don't know
like 20
for three rides or whatever it was did
you ever feel like you're in danger
i mean i did the brakes the first two
times and third time was when i let it
go oh no break
uh the third time i didn't use the brake
there were nets on the side of it at
certain places and i was like those nets
are there for a reason
for phones i think they're for people
because it's just a regular seat belt
it's not even a five-point harness
see if i mean there's a sense of danger
um went trout fishing
in a pond filled with farm trout which
is
probably a controversial thing uh but
uh my my uh
niece adeline loves to fish she does
i mean she had like she brought her
fishing poles multiple poles
she has like fishing brand like hats and
shirts that like have fishing brands on
you know on them
really and um we kept talking about how
we got to find a place to catch some
trout we're like looking in like
passing like rivers and streams and
stuff and then on the way out at the
bottom of the grandfather mountain
it says trout fishing i was like okay
well
let's just go there and just go there
and there's just a pond with a bunch of
trout that you can literally just see
and you literally like try to like get
them to bite the thing
but she caught three i caught one trout
she caught three trout
well if you can see them and they fillet
them for you right there
and you take home the trout fillets and
you eat them when you get home
so they took them all home to to to
carry
so we it was and you zip i didn't
zipline i played golf
i would have ziplined uh and that was
super fun
now i saw if there were zip lines on the
golf course i might start golfing there
were
three i saw and i'm sure you experienced
this as well like
i saw more rain and heard more thunder
saw more lightning than i have seen
maybe in my time
my last decade in california like every
day
there was like a little thunderstorm you
know uh which i kind of i kind of missed
that
yeah you don't see that i've already
seen heard thunder three times in
california um the smell of an oncoming
storm
but one of the funnier things that
happened was
we went to this steakhouse one night
and you know we had a big group yeah i
guess our table
was like 10 people so they had set us up
in the middle of the main dining area
at the biggest table and
this is a place it's a steakhouse so
they serve prime rib
which a few people in our party got
prime rib okay
and then at some point during the
the meal my sister-in-law my brother's
wife teresa
that's how sister-in-laws work she
well actually no because my
sister-in-law could also be my wife's
sister
that's also how they work two different
ways there's probably a third way
i can't think of it right now she texts
that's the stuff she's thinking about
his step sister she texts
me and cole from the table from the
table
and she's in her text says
the woman behind us at the table right
behind us
just received her prime rib and is
giving it back
to the waiter because she thought it was
going to be ribs
is she looking over your shoulder and
seeing this happen
you think that's funny huh yeah i think
it's hilarious i mean a prime rib
does sound like the best ribs like it's
one no it sounds like one good rip
one like give me your primus rib
uh so of course the mclaughlins have fun
with stuff like this you know you've
been around the mclaughlins yeah yeah
yeah we love it when somebody gives us a
reason to make fun of them
uh now of course we don't do it to their
face we just have fun with it as a
family i mean
apparently i don't wanna i'm not gonna
make the i'm not gonna point it out i'm
not gonna laugh
at the woman you know i don't know you
know
i don't know where she's from if she's
from america
then i don't know how she got to this
point she was probably 30
i don't know how she got to 30 not
knowing that prime rib is not a rib
but it can happen then the
conversation i'm sympathetic
why you know what prime rib is i didn't
eat a burrito until i was in college
she's 30 and it's 20 21 i'm saying it's
just an
unusual thing right i mean one of the
two words
in the title is rich it is from the rib
but it is not the what you it is not it
is the only place i've seen a prime rib
like when i think about primary i think
about like
a banquet at an at a hotel
like a i don't know why but like we
would have banquet dining
at in for like uh conferences and then
that's where
there'd be a guy slicing prime rib in
the corner yeah
and so either that or like a wedding
type thing
but if you haven't been to a hotel
banquet then maybe
and you've never ordered it i mean you
don't
uh maybe if you're a vegetarian and you
haven't had that much interaction with
meat but she's obviously there ordering
what she thinks is ribs it is funny
though so go ahead
so then the conversation turned to
because what ended up happening
is she wanted to give it back now i
understand if you think you're getting
ribs and you get prime rib i mean
primarily
it's a big slab of meat just for the
those of you who don't know
it's very pink i don't like that and
it's very it's if it's done correctly
it's done
you know medium rare so yes it is pink
and if you if you like meat in that way
which
objectively is the correct way to like
meat uh
then it's gonna look pink but if you
don't like that it's gonna be gross and
you're gonna be like i thought i was
gonna get some ribs with some sauce on
it
and so then you're going to want to give
it back so then the guy that she was
with
who we thought was maybe a boyfriend but
we didn't know if it was an early date
or a late date you know like this first
date
we started to talk about was this a
surprise to him
as well or is it a surprise to him that
the woman he's on a date with doesn't
know what prime rib is
and if he were a mclaughlin it would be
over
well it would be uh it would be a red
flag
you know we give people some chances i
wouldn't
i wouldn't break up with someone because
they didn't know who what prime rib was
but then i would ask a few questions
about it and i would find out why
and then i might break up with them
depending on the answer why yeah
but we could never date this
is probably true like
but i don't know what all this fan
fiction is about it would never work
yeah right you just don't know enough
it put us into a jolly mood right okay
and so i'm sitting next to my brother
now we moved beyond prime rib lady
that just that she just primed the pump
if you know what i mean i got you
and so now we're just having fun i'll
take the prime
pump and so you know how my brother is
yeah and you know how my brother laughs
and you know how i laugh
he la he's like so if i'm really tickled
at something i go
yeah right and i scream and it's and
it's
loud yeah and it's in a small relatively
small steakhouse
everyone can hear it my brother bit on
the ass
by somebody brother does it twice as
loud
and four times as often as that
i mean that is what he does and so if he
really likes it he'll like
force it yeah and it's in it it's jolly
making
it it's like a it's a reward it's like
it's a it's a gift
to those who are sharing in the
experience like he finds it so funny
he's forcing it into like um
like a megaphone but it's not a gift to
anyone else in the restaurant
no let me just be clear about that it's
it's
it's almost scary well cause you're like
how could someone
right be laughing that loud here
over and over again and so then my mom
starts getting a little embarrassed
okay but one of the things that
really gives my gets my brother going
is my mom cannot stand it
when he curses and so he curses
[Laughter]
because it makes him laugh so much the
way that she responds
so we got into this we just we're
laughing so much and then now teresa
she's saying the table behind you is
very unhappy
it's like we were ruining people's
dinners yeah
i feel bad about it it can happen a
number of ways
like none it it it can't
impact any other table in a positive way
it can be distracting
it can be annoying it can be scary what
what are these noises that people are
making is this how they communicate
what's wrong with them are they being
bitten on the ass by badgers
right or are they trying to vaccinate
themselves it could be it could just be
envy it's like i wish i could have half
as much fun as there ever right now we
were having too much fun for a
steakhouse i'm the first i'm over here
having no fun compared to these yeah
but we were we were having too much fun
for a steakhouse also a shout out to
let me just say random steakhouse let me
just say no it's called stone walls
okay in uh in banner elk
and after we finished the loud meal
uh several of the staff were mythical
beasts
and we got a picture together now
i don't know what your experience was
and it's been a while since we've been
out and
we've been out you know what i'm saying
period yeah and i
and north carolina is our home state
it's where we got started you know it'll
always be our home
and so it's not i would say that more
people in north carolina than most
states
might be familiar with us just because
we're the hometown boys
um but it still is unusual
to be recognized or for somebody to be a
fan right i mean it's like it's still
it's still a sporadic experience even
when you're in north carolina
but let me tell you about this coming
out of the covet hole and then being
recognized
it's like there's a reacquaintance to it
the people
of the banner elk area that is a
mythical beast
sebastian holt we got the white the
people at the white water rafting
company edge of the world shout out to
the edge of the world folks
several mythical beasts there um
mythical beasts brett
actually was my uh river guide it took
me down the river
uh we got uh what i i want to talk about
that but let's go
i'll come back to that we got mythical
beasts at the alpine roller coaster
we got mythical beasts at stonewall
restaurant
i mean it and i was just like this is
this is
it's a stronghold um they've set up camp
here in the mountains
i i mean just just to spoil their alert
for what's coming
next week it's like it i don't know if
you've got more
if you had more fun but you know i
didn't do anything like you did i'm
pretty upset with you right now
good i'm very envious i'm at the other
table
saying man share a little of the fun
that was my intention
but that being said i did notice um
like when we would eat i mean if we did
eat out it was like eating outdoors at
like more of a fast food type place
going from
one family member's house to another
type situation
and there were way too many
instances of i mean the kids would say
you're being recognized right now and
but then we wouldn't be approached
which is which is nice when we're eating
and then
but people would then drive off and
there were lots of people
yelling get me the commanding from cars
there was a lot of i mean again i'm in
the p i'm in the piedmont
i'm in the middle i don't i can't speak
for banner elk but there's a lot of
shouting from
cars and uh a lot of people who
who did talk to me every single person
who mentioned my name
thought my name was rhett well good like
my marketing plan is working
like everyone you know it's like
rhett i'll be like close
but i get called link it happens it
happened a few times
i wasn't called link once i was probably
called rhett
eight times it annoyed my family more
than me because
i kind of know that's like okay first of
all you know the level of mythical
beasts
if they don't know which one i am right
yeah that's not that's not a magical
it also means they don't know which one
you are right by the way yeah so it's
not it's just my name's first
name so they're just going for it yeah
so i don't take it personally
but i did i thought it was sweet that my
family
thought i might be taking it personally
when i was at the beach which i also
played golf at the beach so i
i had i had a golf outing in the
mountains and the beach
the the chorus on the beach was on the
sound
and we played so it was me uh my
brother-in-law chris
and then lance our friend from bearden
lady
maker of beard oil and lip balms
extraordinaire
uh of lance and lacy we played and they
pair and they paired us up
with a guy who's playing by himself
david
from virginia shout out to david civil
engineer
shout out virginia you gotta you gotta
calm it down he
was a mythical beast as well and he
didn't tell me until we were
a couple of holes in a couple holes in
but he played it cool that's good he
he called me link a couple of times
during the round
so that makes you feel any better good
shot link
really yeah and then he'd be like man
i've called you a link a couple of times
i was like
dude i answered to both i answered both
especially when i got a shot like that
one people i'm all in the links i when
people do that i just let
i you know i let it go it's never it's
never it's not worth correcting it's
totally fine
so um so anyway we great time in the
mountains well you went to
what class rapids three is the top
this is the uh okay taga river so this
is the river that
the namesake of the watauga medical
center
which by the way yes do you know where
the kids ziplined
hawke's nest where i broke the site of
your incredible
pelvis breaking and concussion event so
it's during the summer
it's zip lining and maybe mountain
biking or whatever yeah
uh i'll never forget so that's a sign
well i'll
actually continually continue remember
for the first time
it was the otago river which is a
beautiful river you have broken your
pelvis you were at watauga medical
center but really what they do
is there's one class three rapid you
have a concussion and they have
uh this particular rafting company edge
of the world
according to them they're the only
rafting company in that does the watauga
river
that owns or leases the land next to the
class
three so what they do is i know what
they do you stop at the class three you
eat lunch and then you
walk back up with your rafts and you go
through as many times as you want oh
that's cool
uh so i'll put some pictures up uh
uh that we that were taking as we went
through the anybody fall out
uh no one fell out but
shepard got close i would love to go
whitewater rafting again remember that
time
we went i mean this is when i still
worked at ibm or like right after that
we went white water rafting at
in west virginia that was the upper
gauley upper gauley which definitely has
class five
that was awesome and so i think it turns
it gets to six during certain points of
the year
my dad was there yeah and greg's dad and
greg you know how greg's dad rode the
bull on the front
yeah so what they do on this class three
which is significantly smaller is
they put people on the front you can
ride the bull you can put two people on
the front
and then if multiple people want to they
put you sideways and you go down
sideways with everybody sitting on one
side of the raft
and then other people sitting and like
holding i was like holding shepherd or
holding adeline like from the back
you know trying to keep them from
falling in they we had a blast man
um and then we drove across the state
oh well speaking of mythical beasts like
owen wilson in the royal tenenbaums
right now
i so much want to be a part of your
family huh okay well just might be
arranged
just for the activities not i mean you
might be too judgy
the prime rib and all oh well i'm not
making him even more jealous
when i get to the air i got i landed and
got my rental car
and the guy this happens often people
look at me and look up and see how big i
am
and then say things like depending on
what your profession is if you're a
rental car guy you say
you need a upgrade to more legroom
mm-hmm
and i was like okay he said i'll give
you a free upgrade to more legroom and
of course i'm not going to turn that
down he says okay your car is in
spot so and so it's a dodge
charger that has more legroom i don't
think so
i don't i think you're just trying to
get rid of it like a sports car
which was weird and loud and i drove
this black dodge charger
all around north carolina it was so loud
and it i don't know i kind of felt like
hey i'm in north carolina i'm driving a
charger
anyway i'm driving the charger across
the state oh my god
to get to the mountains and i've got
shepherd and his cousin who's my
brother's
uh youngest child who is the same age as
shepherd they're two peas in the pod
love each other love hanging out with
each other so i've got shepard and
adeline with me
we needed to stop and pick up a couple
of last minute supplies before we got to
the place so we stopped at a
super walmart great somewhere
in the western parts of north carolina
a few mythical beasts working at this
walmart
now shepard being a los angeles kid
doesn't have a lot of experience with
walmart
much less super walmarts it's
i don't think he understood that we were
walking into
essentially a town do you know what i'm
saying
yes i i we actually went into walmart
when i visited my dad
lando and i went in a walmart because i
had to get some i had to get
my version of coffee like i can't have
any
family members version of coffee because
who knows what you'll get
um and we were walking through walmart
and lando goes
i don't think i've ever been in one of
these places yeah
it's crazy how big it is there is one in
burbank but we don't go in
so what i didn't doesn't is that super
no it's not super
i mean this thing there's nothing in los
angeles this is this big maybe the tar
pits i don't know
it's just like i mean it's so big and
i failed to orient shepard to that
fact and so we go to
uh a particular section and i'm kind of
looking for something
and then i kind of turn around and i'm
like
shepherd and adeline are gone and then
it immediately hits me i'm like
this is a super walmart
this is like someone this is like your
kid
you're at disneyland and the kid is you
can't find your kid
you start thinking logistical questions
like who do i talk to
do i need to go to the speaker yeah of
course i was like
do the smart thing stay in this section
because they'll come back because
they're not
stupid they're just not thinking right
now okay i stayed
in the pharmacy section for about eight
minutes
during which i was party to a
conversation
or at least listening in on a
conversation there was a dude
who was in the stop smoking section
of the super walmart which in this part
of north carolina this is a big section
okay okay we got a lot of people who
need to stop smoking
okay yeah and he was doing the wife on
speaker thing and he was like all right
honey which one do you want
she's like what he's like which
patch do you want
well what are they well
they got five now you're only you're
only quoting his side of the
conversation but
this is back and forth oh because it's
awesome they sound the same
pretty much okay and
he says well one of them's got three
stages
she's like what three stages
[Laughter]
well how much is that one 75 dollars
good lord what else have they got so
that was it was a lot of that
it's like a rocket yeah it's like where
do you land on that one they they
settled for
a lower tier one what you might call a
bottom shelf nicotine patch
but after this conversation had come and
gone uh
no shepherd and adeline and so i just
made the decision to be like well they
probably went to
the toy section which is right next to
the sporting goods they weren't in the
stop smoking section which would have
been my first guest right
so i go there they're not there and then
i'm like okay now now
now i've done it you got to get on the
mic well i proceeded please tell me you
got on the mic
i proceeded to do a lap
which takes eight minutes now you you i
know shepard well enough to know
that i would not be concerned that he
would be scared oh he wasn't scared no
right he would he was only scared of
what i was going to say when i found him
you know he might be avoiding he's
scared of me
right but he's not scared of walmart
yeah
so i go back to i've got go back to the
pharmacy
and i wait for another couple minutes
and i'm like that's it i'm going i'm
going to the speaker and then i turn
around and they're walking up i thought
he had a phone
he didn't take it into the walmart okay
i left it in the car left it in the
charger
you should you should have gone to the
speaker to to give him
well i wanted to i was like not only is
this going to find them but it's going
to teach them a lesson
uh anyway we had some words after that
mostly like shepherd this is a super
walmart
yeah you'll probably never be in another
one again but
just in case it's like a black hole you
could have never come back
yeah this is like going into a national
park you don't go in without a plan
you don't go in without a map you don't
go in without some form of communication
and an exit strategy you know what i'm
saying i mean i think all you had to do
was pull up people of walmart before you
go
in and he would have entered with
trepidation um
i hope that's still going it has to be
so
well i'm apparently i'm sure it is so
then we finish our incredible
action-packed mountain trip with the
trip
just me and shepherd driving in a
charger right across the piedmont no
broken ankles stopped
in winston-salem
not for the cigarettes but for i wanted
to show shepard old salem
because stevie's always talking about
old school he's talking about
this is her favorite place in the world
it's like colonial williamsburg but in
winston-salem and uh i was like well
this will be fun it's right off the
highway
we're driving through it anyway uh old
salem
at the time was closed so it's just all
all the buildings like there's none of
the people dressed up
in character uh
so since covert they really haven't yeah
i think they've been closed for a long
time well good you encountered a little
disappointment
so old salem was just a bunch of clothes
we did use the bathroom
there we go why are you getting this
detail because we got a guy to open it
up for us
he was the one that told me the deal
he's like i can open up the bathroom for
you but everything else is closed
okay this is an important podcast i mean
you got to choose what you're going to
tell us about well i just i mean i took
a leak
so then i get to the beach
now uh how long of a drive was that it
was six and a half hours
because we had to get up to uh
my in-laws have a have a place up on
are you okay i need a kleenex
my nose is kind of something about
something about this room you're jealous
of my vacation you're allergic to
other people having a good time a little
nasal drip so
we get to uh it's not really a beach
house it's at the beach but it's a spot
on uh sort of a branch of the noose
river
kind of like the sound area you know
there's so much there's so much like
fingers of water that come into the
north carolina coast if you look at the
map right i did look at a map
and it's just amazing what all those
fingers do is they can create
just miles and miles and miles of more
shoreline
than you get in most states definitely
more than you get
you know what i'd like to see somebody
do the math on the amount of shoreline
in north carolina versus
california which california has almost
the whole half of the entire united
states
yet it doesn't have a bunch of
meandering things so i think
they made me pretty close north carolina
might have more i don't know i can't
believe that
i mean if you count both sides of the
other side of the outer banks
man anyway it's awesome and they have a
spot that's way way way way
way out in the middle of nowhere like 30
minutes from anything that you need
well if you've seen the notebook you
know what's what we're talking about
yeah it's that
it's this old house that they've really
kind of fixed up and it's like an airbnb
situation but
you know the family had reserved it for
this for this week
and um you know just having a great time
is pretty low key out there you like can
kind of kayak out into the sound and
that kind of thing
well like two days into the trip and
this is when we
did and this is when uh lance and lacy
and their kids
joined us so this is basically my
brother and sister-in-law
lance and lacy and their kids me and
shepherd
and my in-laws have a place on the beach
so we're kind of like getting together
with them but they're not staying at
this place
and there is like there was a pretty
much every day there was a thunderstorm
now there was a thunderstorm in
the morning like very early in the
morning
and lacey was actually like downstairs
having coffee at like 7 a.m
and she said that it sounded like
lightning
struck in the backyard like she said she
heard like a sucking sort of
boom before the boom wow a sucking
yeah and immediately the power goes out
of course i remember that lightning
strike because it woke me up
but i also didn't think at the time the
power's out because it was still
dark as far as i can remember anyway i
wake up at
you know i'm sleeping late because of
the
time difference yeah and so i'm like i'm
waking up at like nine o'clock and then
like there's a text from my
sister-in-law and she's like the power's
out we've gone
order the prime rib to dunkin donuts to
get coffee and breakfast
because we can't make any stuff in fact
and there's a way the way that this
works because it's at
sea level maybe that's the reason you
don't have water there's no water in the
house when the what powers out because
it works off of a pump
so we don't have water or electricity
can't wash your hands
so we're all sitting down they get back
and we break out the dunkin donuts
coffee and
biscuits etc we're enjoying our time
together
this is when i started to communicate
with you because we were supposed to
have our
company-wide meeting via zoom
yeah and i was like i got no power
so i can't do that yeah and you were you
had something dial-up
at the house i'm at right now so we had
to postpone that but anyway
as we're sitting there eating a late
breakfast
powers back somebody they saw a crew as
they were coming in and they saw a crew
was working on the transformer at the
top of the neighborhood so
we don't think that the lightning strike
in the backyard cut our power out we
think that
it maybe was actually a little bit
further away anyway so it was several
houses so somebody called
they've restored power within hours so
power's back up we're like all right
back to business
five minutes into the power being back
on
first person to say anything was lacey
and she said
what's that smell um i think there's
plat this
smells like plastic is burning so we
immediately are like oh
probably somebody left something on a
burner somebody left something in the
oven
and like it's come back on so we're like
looking around the kitchen
and then as we're sort of following the
smell towards the laundry room right
when
i can't remember who was first someone
was first in line gets to
the threshold to the laundry room
there's a giant
pop on the electrical panel there's two
electrical panels right there
and at that point i look at the
electrical panel
and you know how like you've got the
metal sort of face of an electrical
panel and then you've got
all the switches in the middle for the
fuses right yeah
and there's like a crack behind it that
you can sort of look through and see
sort of normally you don't see anything
it's just darkness
there were flames flames full like not
just like a flicker
a raging fire
behind the electrical panel just like
this whole thing is on fire and it's
plastic that is on fire
good gosh this is the fire i was hearing
about
i learned a few things if you're
following along i learned some things
about myself
because i've never been in a house fire
before right yeah
uh the first thing that i thought
thankfully was where's shepard
it wasn't where's my laptop so i was
proud of myself
okay you know what i mean yeah good dad
i mean my laptop is backed up in the
cloud
shepard is not so
i i'm like and i we don't know where the
kids are at because they've been gone
and this is a big house three stories
there's a crow's nest thing at the top
the kids we let the kids do whatever
they wanted to so we didn't know if they
were hot they play hide and seek all the
time
so the first thing i'm thinking
situation also i also
learned that i immediately went to the
worst case scenario i was 100 convinced
that the house was going to burn down
i was like we can't put that fire out
what are you going to do throw water on
it no you shouldn't do that
but i did stop a second and think fire
extinguisher
but then there was talk of do we have a
fire extinguisher
and then ashley sister-in-law says
there's one on the top floor
so my nephew isaiah runs to the top
floor
he comes back down with the fire
extinguisher
in the and also at during that time
uh someone points out that the kids are
all outside down at the dock like
playing
swimming or something this is happening
pretty quickly the fire hasn't
spread from the box right but it was
just it felt like it was a matter of
time that the flames are going to come
out and then catch the wall on fire at
which point
we're just gonna have to get i was
thinking like okay i know shepard's safe
what do i what did i bring that i should
get out of the house because
i don't think i'm gonna die but like i i
don't want to be inconvenienced to this
level
as well right it's like i mean yeah my
my laptop is backed up but
this you're thinking this before the
fire extinguisher yes
yeah um and then i was like man i've got
like a lot of like
you know moisturizers and like ointments
and stuff that i just
i kind of use just to make myself happy
and
uh regulated and stuff and yeah yeah
it's like i've got my fiber i brought my
fiber i got to get the fiber because i
don't have to go back to the super
walmart and get lost to get the phone
you know these are the things these are
the things that are running through my
mind
very very quickly and i'm like what
clothes do i have i think i brought a
lot of i brought a lot of shirts
and brought all my shorts you brought a
lot of shirts i don't want to get my
i don't want to buy any shorts i just
got a couple pairs of shorts that i was
excited about wearing haven't worn them
in on this trip how many shirts
you said a lot i mean more than i needed
too many shirts i brought too many
shirts give me a number
13 shirts damn okay and by then the fire
extinguisher
comes back down and also by then chris
who was the most level-headed person
in the crew at this point yeah uh was
thinking
what should have been obvious i think i
should be cutting the power
off now it wasn't so obvious to him that
we could also go outside and hit the
master switch
so what he was doing is he was grabbing
anything he could think of to try and
hit the main switch on the
deal and the closest thing to him was a
bottle of bleach oh my god
he was using a bottle of bleach to hit a
fire well which
it was almost empty but also as he picks
it up he realizes that the top
is not screwed on because again nothing
against my sister-in-law
but it is a family tradition in my
wife's family
to just put tops on things without
screwing them you just as long as the
top is
in contact with something it is
considered closed
as you can imagine this we know what
prime rib is that's your side
this this leads to several problems
including when you're trying to put
fire out with bleach oh my god uh but he
realized it
and was able to well i think i think he
ended up using a paper towel roll which
is also flammable but it was the nearest
thing
to hit the switch and it went off and
when it
when he hit it and it went off
the fire slowly
went down and just turned to smoke which
then now the whole house is beginning to
smell like
that crazy burnt plastic but we're like
thinking we hear a sizzle but we think
that the fire is out so we don't have to
but we're ready with the fire i wouldn't
have thought that turning the power off
would have stopped the fire because at
that point i wouldn't think that it's
not like the electricity is fueling the
fire i think that it is though i think
that in this case
the electricity was still coming in
there
and re-sparking and fuel and fueling it
to some degree
okay and then uh credit to me the one
thing that i did right in this situation
is i was like i bet you there's a switch
outside and i went and there was a
master switch and i cut that
off so now power so did anyone use the
extinguisher because
no no no we didn't it's not like you get
the extinguisher and it's like well
there's different types of extinguishers
and i've never really
used one because you don't want to use
it because then it won't be usable later
uh do you hold it upside down i think
that
it's a it's an electrical fire should i
use the powder one
i don't know the answer to whether which
one you should what you can use
i think you can probably use either one
of them it's a wake-up call whenever you
go into a new environment
know where the fire extinguishers are
there should be at least one on every
floor
yeah yeah but hey listen we the first
time in a house fire and it really
wasn't a house fire it was a small
electrical fire that ended up being
contained
but what that led to the only time i
used a fire extinguisher was in
uh the t-shirt war video yeah which was
a mistake
oh my god because it was the you set one
of those powder ones off and it's like
you're cleaning it out for days
we just left it in there it was
everywhere um
but now we couldn't stay there because
they literally had to do a full panel or
place
two panels yeah which is something that
takes a a long time and was going to
take at least the rest of the week so we
ended up joining
my in-laws and their place which is on
the beach
in emerald isle um
which is an awesome place to stay so it
wasn't like i mean it was
it was kind of an upgrade in some ways
right so
but then the last piece of my
vacation that i found
really satisfying
was something that we started doing
for the like last three nights that we
were there
and you know you know lance and lacey
and so they've always got something that
they kind of
like they want you to watch or whatever
and they want to watch it with you and
then talk about it right
and they like watching a movie and then
having a discussion
that's cool we should do first of all i
like watching half a movie and falling
asleep but go ahead
we should do we should do that specific
thing more often
like i actually thought to myself like a
book club but for movies
yeah but like it's got to be it's got to
be a movie that's thought provoking
and usually i mean there are there are
fictional
movies like narrative movies that kind
of
maybe scratch that itch but jackass is
coming out but it's really
it's really documentaries that kind of
get you thinking a little bit more
things that are a little bit outside the
box so
we've talked about this uh talked about
in the mythical society ama recently but
uh they have been saying you gotta watch
bo burnham's inside right
and i was like well you know what i'm
gonna wait i'm gonna wait to watch it
with you guys at the beach and now
secretly
as i said in the ama yesterday there i
always have a little bit of a hesitation
yeah to watch something
from someone who is kind of doing a
similar thing to us
but in my estimation doing it better
right like i just think that bo burnham
is so talented and i think he's so funny
and so original and innovative
and you know and so it's there's this
there is a it's not that he's actually
doing a similar thing but he started on
youtube well he was musical comedy
he's doing this i'm saying his approach
to comedy and the fact that he's a
musical comedian
and also the fact that a lot of people
are like our music people have been
talking about how our music sounds
similar in some ways
you know but i was like i don't really
want to watch it because i know it's
going to just give me this like artistic
angst and frustration that i get
sometimes when i
see somebody do something really really
well and i'm like i don't want to be
able to do something like that i want to
be able to do something with that kind
of impact right
right or wrong or whether or not this is
based in any rel you know reality or if
it's just a delusion it's a problem for
me to be able to just sit back and free
myself up to enjoy oh no i
totally get it i mean i that's why i had
not watched it
like lily watched it and we were going
to watch it together but then when she
watched it alone
that drastically decreased the chances
of me watching it because like
it was watching with her was going to
put me over the edge to overcome what
you're describing
well we watched it and i and i you know
it was therapeutic for me to tell lance
and lacy right up front
because they because they completely
understood i was like my hesitation to
watch this is
what i just described is like i know how
it's going to make me feel because i
know i'm going to like it and think it's
great
and then i'm going to start thinking
about why haven't we done something like
that right
like that's what it's going to do to me
and so i just have to prepare myself
going in yeah
but acknowledging that and kind of
speaking it before it happened kind of
freed me up to be like
to to put myself in the the opposite you
know the observer's seat to observe
myself watching it
but also to be able to enjoy it and i
did you know i i really
you need you've watched it now we're not
we're not going to spend a lot of time
talking about
why inside is is great but i mean
it is in my estimate it is great but it
is i mean it does help
with uh the way that we would process it
to
to know that he experienced such a
torturous experience himself that i'm
not envious of
right yeah yeah yeah yeah so but then
we had this what ended up being also a
very therapeutic conversation as
i am and lance and lazy as well we were
kind of like just talking about what it
made us think about
and spent quite a lot of time kind of
talking about like
the way it made us feel
about somebody doing something like that
because they in the same way have
like these aspirations for things
they're trying to do and so that was
that was awesome
and then the next night we all watched
uh another thing i'm giving a bunch of
recommendations and i'll probably just
pick one for
next week to be my actual recommendation
when you talk about because i know it's
your recommendation today
oh we watched another thing that i think
you should watch that a lot of people
talked about but for some reason
completely mis my radar missed it was
there's a hulu
special called in and of itself um i
haven't seen it
which is i don't want to say anything
about it because if i describe it in any
way
i feel like you're going to bring some
kind of you're gonna bring something
into it that may
taint your experience but the discussion
that we had
we talked for like two hours it's a
documentary
no it's a special it's a special but
it's not a comedy special oh
okay here's what i'll tell you it's a
show that a guy did in a small theater
in new york city like 552 times and then
they filmed
you know a bunch of them and put it
together into the special on hulu
and it's just the thing i was
watching inside and then watching in and
of itself i was just like man
the standard for specials
has just gone up so much like you can't
just be
funny or you can't just be impressive in
the way that this particular guy is
impressive given his profession which i
don't want to say what it is because
then you'll judge it
um you got to do something
that is original and you got to do
something that is innovative and you got
to do something that
challenges a paradigm you got to do
something that is vulnerable and
personal like you know what i'm saying i
was just
struck with the choices that both of
these guys made
in order to do something that actually
gets noticed in this media landscape
that has so
many choices is there a sock puppet
there's no sock puppet
okay and then the last night we watched
another documentary with everybody kids
included
which i can heartily recommend and i can
tell you a little bit about it because
it's not the kind of thing that
can be spoiled some kind of heaven which
you will love
which is a documentary about the
villages
retirement community in florida the
world's largest retirement community
and there's a young filmmaker lance
oppenheim i think is his name
he's only 25 years old i think he made
this thing you know when he's 22 or
something
and uh it's just it's in the tradition
of an arrow morris
documentary okay uh in the way that so
it's people it's a portrait of people
oriented very much about people and
these
you know older people trying to in their
golf carts
find all the golf carts to find
identity and belonging and
relationship and connection uh super
funny but also
just very poignant um and we
we talked about that uh and then and
again and then we were like
hey well there's one more let's do one
more and we watch the netflix
documentary called tell me who i am
which get is it has some sensitive is a
trigger warning definitely
you should read about it if you're if
you if the idea of there needing to be a
trigger warning for anything but i can't
tell you what it is because then it
spoils it
so if you don't want it to be spoiled
i'm just saying
but anyway if you don't want to be
triggered you need to be spoiled if you
don't want to be spoiled you might get
triggered
right and this one is just this fast
again it's just like
super fascinating and original like this
one particular
situation that could only happen seems
like it only happened like one time in
the history of the world and these guys
documented it and we just sat there and
talked about that too i mean
i was going to bed at like 1 00 a.m 2
a.m and i was always
the first one to go to bed and they were
like talking crap to me because i was
going to bed
but you're on pacific time anyway i just
i got to say
that and it's not to make you feel bad
about your
time but it was a really fulfilling time
like had this
activity filled time in the mountains
and then had this
uh you know we had lived through a fire
and then to have these
like film forum discussions late at
night i just had a really good time
and i honestly didn't know one of the
things that i was thinking
that i was a little bit apprehensive and
anxious about
and uh maybe you'll talk about this next
week but you know this is the first time
back in north carolina since
going public on this podcast about the
fact that we're not christians anymore
that's right and going back to a place
where being
a christian is a much more important
part of identity and the culture it's
much more influential in the culture
than it is in california um out here
it's just like oh you're not a christian
anymore cool
there it's not a christian anymore why
what's wrong with you
yeah um and i kind of i actually had
this expectation that i would get into a
bunch of conversations about that
and i was like trying to think about
like i don't want to be argumentative
and i'm not trying to like
defend myself and debate i just want to
love people
and i you know but it honestly did not
it wasn't a thing it wasn't a thing
and we just everyone just had a good
time together
and just kind of connected through
enjoying things together
so it was a good it was a good time
obviously i wish
jesse and locke had been there but it
was a good time for me and shepard
shepard is like i mean
i i kind of just every once in a while i
would just sort of see him roll past me
and he would just be like covered in
something
the last thing that he had gotten into
you know sort of like this let loose in
the wilderness kind of feel you know
i like look outside and i'd see him dr
riding this golf cart through the big
front yard of the place
on the river and he would be like going
full speed and then he'd be getting out
running next to it and he was ghost
riding the golf cart at full speed i
mean again this is not
safe but he needs a little bit of not
safe in his life you know
uh because he lives in the city so
it was a good time for him as well well
i'm glad you had a great time
you know i celebrate i celebrate that i
mean it wasn't
i i don't know you know i got a little
time to continue to process my
experience to pull it all together you
know i think that i think that
i think it's uh i think there's a good
i think there's a good takeaway there
but sometimes it
i'm glad i got a i got a little more
time to
to process but uh yeah i look forward to
telling you about it if you can hold on
just hold on till next week so i got a
wreck
right i mean you've been full of wrecks
yeah uh today
mine one of the milestones of my three
week trip
something that i was looking forward to
for
months um
something that um yeah i just
you know i had no control over when it
was going to arrive but i knew when it
did it was going to change my life
and that is the new john mayer album
now i mean of course you know i'm i'm
not a fan of john mayer's music
i'm now a fan of john mayer the person
like i am i'm a fan girl i mean i told
the guy that i love him
right and you know what i stand by it
okay and i'm i think my mission in life
the thing that lily and i were talking
about we're the the neils are all fans
of john mayer i'm recommending his new
album it's called sob rock
um he in in all of his discussions about
it he doesn't
use the phrase yacht rock ever
but he's he's channeling that energy i
don't know if you've listened to it yet
yeah i have uh he's channeling that
energy but like the subject matter
a lot of people when they define yacht
rock they forget that the subject matter
is a part of it that it's like
it's about yachts it's one no it's just
it's not about anything
too heavy it's not about anything that
will make you sob
right yeah so it's i think he took this
this is just my description of it
he took the styling the stylings of
yacht rock as an inspiration
and you know he's a lot more eloquent
than
than i am in talking about how he put
this album together
but just in simple layman's terms
the subject matter is more sobby you
know it's like
unrequited love and him being our age
like literally same age as us but not
not having somebody so it actually makes
me feel good on that front too that's
like man i got something john mayer
doesn't have
and that wants desperately yeah which is
it may be some woman
from his distant past that he keeps
writing messages to her in way too many
songs
it's great it's it's it's a light listen
it's 40 minutes
um i love how he went
about the marketing for the thing and
like this bold choice
with all of his marketing to like really
lean into it you might think that it's
parody
until you listen to it and it's like
okay this this actually works
yeah i read it some needle i really like
it and um
i was talking to lily about how i think
my mission in life is to find a way to
just be friends with the guy
um you'll be disappointed he's not a
hero i don't he's not a hero
i mean he'll disappoint you i think yeah
i think you should hold on to the idea
of being friends with him
yeah but not actually not actually not
actually be friends with him i recommend
cybrock
check it out my favorite song is wild
blue right now
got a little dire straight vibe
happening
sultan's of swing you know that song
anyway that's my wreck
well thanks for joining us on this ride
uh link will
take the wheel next week and uh
get a little bit more serious to watch
more ear biscuits click on the playlist
on the right to watch the previous
episode of your biscuits click on the
playlist to the left and don't forget to
click on the circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best